good morning John it is Monday Tuesday's
Tuesday it's Monday I think that Monday
is Tuesday
no it's Tuesday it's definitely Tuesday
good morning Thomas Tuesday but I have
no idea what date it is because it took
me that long to figure out what freaking
day of the week it was how am I gonna
know what date a month it is been an
exciting time moving in getting used to
our new place and for the first time not
so long after we moved in ourselves we
have guests we have Brian and Jesslyn
who you may remember from such videos as
William is B when I'm gone from your
pants
it was Brennan Just Lunch anniversary
yesterday one of the things that we did
is we went into the recording studio and
we recorded some songs with them Brian
is an absolutely fantastic guitarist and
songwriter and Jesslyn is a wonderful
singer and so is Catherine and together
all three of them recorded this song
which I was gonna play in the background
of this video because I loved it I loved
it a lot and now we're about to go to a
friend's house for his birthday party
it's gonna be nice relaxing evening with
stew soup stew in soup so John well you
are undoubtedly freaking out all over
the United States of America I have
actually had a little bit of a chance to
tiny bit of a chance teeny-tiny to relax
can you believe it
I can imagine your jealousy right now I
have to say that I'm a tiny bit jealous
of you because you're always calling me
during nerdfighter events being like hey
everybody talked to Hank and everybody
like hi hey and I'm like oh I was just
sitting here chilling out I guess I
could have been having a really good
time right now I'm ambivalent to go both
ways grass is always greener so on and
so forth
John's basket is better than my basket
that's sort of how Brotherhood works
you always have better baskets at each
other don't actually know what I'm
talking it's very echoey in this room
I'm sorry it's so ugly in this room I
really need to get some stuff on the
walls we have this bookshelf
and that is it and we have our books we
have big stacks of books that are going
on the bookshelf that have not been
finished yet
because I got really angry at the
instructions for building the bookshelf
and I had to stop building the bookshelf
or else I would have killed myself and
the bookshelf there are tons of people
who are now eligible for the Paper Towns
collab album if you don't know what I'm
talking about click here and I haven't
sent out the gladden to anybody but
we'll be putting the digitized version
online pretty soon and we will email all
of you when that happens I'm sorry it
hasn't happened to faster it is ready
but it takes a little bit of time to
copy and paste everybody's email address
so that we can send it out to everyone
because there are like hundreds of you
I am freaking impressed I thought like
50 or 60 people would do it and no no
it's been like 50 or 60 people a day so
thank you all very much for doing that
and please continue to so thank you very
much of you who are songs for that and
of course thanking for people who have
done the three challenge items and are
eligible to receive set album if you
like the song that you listen to right
now please comment and say that you like
it because Brian is the man who wrote it
sometimes isn't very compelled for the
internet and I want him to know whether
or not the internet would love have he
ever decided to give the Internet it
change just listen to a little bit more
of it yes mate without a name the
goddamn shame
well you give a meter goes and you give
me gold lapis lazuli and a mirror a
heart never gave me nothing I knew how
to use and the only thing you told me
that I had at you it's a fantastic song
and I was over proud of my friends John
enjoy Melbourne Florida tomorrow and I
will see you tomorrow
[Music]
you